Jimmy and Michael here at CES 2017 we're
checking out HTC vive is sweet and they
released you know they announced a bunch
of new peripherals the first of which
you know I'm holding my hands it's like
it's a new head strap design it's an
add-on for you know just the existing
HTC vive headset but what makes this one
unique is that it's like a hard shell as
opposed to like a claw there's also like
a dial on the back that allows you to
like tighten the straps as well and then
there's like integrated you know
headphones we both had a chance to try
it on you know what did you think I
really I really like the strap on
headset where you can twist it to get in
place because I've had a lot of trouble
with oculus rift and trying to get that
on it fits nicely but it takes a lot of
work with this you just loosen it snap
it on and then twist a little dial right
here and it fits right into place almost
reminiscent of PSV are and then
integrated headphones are similar to
what oculus rift had so they're
combining two of these aspects from
other headset manufacturers putting them
into their own which makes a more
complete headset I believe I think it
also makes it more ergonomic too because
the the regular vibe is really fun every
cut it squeezes to your face the hard
shell makes it a little bit more balance
I think and like you mentioned it's also
much easier to put on you don't have to
like deal with like straps things like
that just one nod that you tighten it's
really easy to do and the headphones I
think or are a nice welcome addition I
wish they kind of shift with it to begin
with but you know better late than never
they did mention that HTC vibes won't
come with this out of the box it will be
like an add-on protocol so the next
thing that we kind of saw was like these
HTC vive trackers which you can kind of
see at the end of this baseball bat here
and what it allows you to do is you can
basically add it onto anything we saw it
added on to like like like guns and
things like that so we played one game
it was like a baseball simulator it's
actually made for
like MLB professionals and using like
m.o.b data on like various pictures and
things like that they can simulate what
it's like to go up against you know
certain pictures and things like that
and you know we both had a chance to try
out the demo I stuck at baseball but you
seem to do a little bit better than I
did you know what you think about its
accuracy so the live tracker it attaches
to the bottom of the bat and I was
surprised by how well was tracking I
mean I'm not the best baseball player in
the world up by any stretch of course
but I felt like the speed of the pitches
along with the tracking of the bat both
worked well with what they're intended
to do so I was speaking with with the
representative there and he was
mentioning that MLB teams are going to
be looking into this with getting
pitcher data putting that into the
simulation and giving about like the
double-a and triple-a teams this
equipment so they can practice against
the top love of pitchers in the major
leagues it's to get an advantage on
opponents in real life it's yeah as you
mentioned we might try to go I thought
of his game it's not it's actually for
professionals anyway yeah and we saw
unlike you know different guns and
things like that as well so you can get
like tract goes I think this one right
here so you have like a really heavy gun
right here you have like the tracker
it's like right on top so you can like
use this to track anything it just uses
that the lighthouses to do the tracking
and it works pretty well the last thing
that we saw was the wireless ad on that
actually kind of like it like sits on
top of the headset and then there's this
like a cable that goes down and two like
this is kind of battery pack they just
like flood into your pocket but other
than that there's like no wires there's
nothing to trip on one concern that I
did have with it was was the added the
agency they would end and because the
problem with latency in VR is that if it
adds too much latency you can get like
judder or
like you can get motion sick I I
personally didn't get motion sick HTC's
you know saying that they're like
advertising around two millisecond
response time which is insanely quick I
we both had a chance to try out what did
you think so I was trying the shooting
game that came along with the wireless
pack and I thought it'd work it was
surprising how well it worked because I
had no concept of how well it was going
to work to begin with so when I was
moving around left and right ducking and
looking over corners and shooting there
everything felt as if I work I was doing
this in a traditional vr setup and I
think that this is the next step to make
room scale vr a closer possibility so
once we once there's more access to the
wireless packs I think you'll also see
developers try and do more room scale
things in their games and I think that's
the next step for VR games you know it
actually isn't made by HTC itself but
HTC is like funding like third-party
hardware manufacturers and and that's
one of them it sounds like it's coming
out like maybe in q2 and like the one
thing that I had to get readjusted to
was you know I haven't used HTC by for
so long I'm accustomed to like not
moving around too much because I don't
want to get tangled up in the cable and
I kind of have to like go through like a
resetting process because like I there
was a moment was like no I can just like
walk around without worrying about
tripping yeah same say for me because
then you see it when you see the
boundary so like oh I can't go there I
can't even like that near that because
I'm worried about my wires and running
into a wall but now it's just like yeah
I three toes let's explore the
boundaries so the only male invitations
now with this device is that you know
how big is your room that's the only
concern left and you know we're excited
to see that their stuff so HTC you know
announced the bunch of cool things for
more awesome tech coverage hang on to
gamespot com
[Music]